Emergency Services raced through the
darkness arriving to find the grand
diamond City Casino engulfed in flames
it took around 11 hours to tame the fire
that broke out just before midnight
some were trapped and could not be saved
others survived but needed immediate
medical attention
many of those who were injured are from
nearby Thailand
victims were sent to hospitals across
the border with reports that at least
one emergency Ward was overwhelmed
Rescue Team searched amongst the smoke
for survivors some are still missing
those who could ran away from the fire
that wasn't an option for those higher
up Witnesses saw desperate people jumped
to their deaths to escape the blaze
other terrified guests got out by
clinging to this crane
the cambodians relied on reinforcements
to tackle the fire
Services over here these are actually
Thai firefighters who've come across the
border to help with the emergency and to
help the rescue trying to uh get into
the places where we thought might still
be people uh trapped
near the flames you can see these New
Year's decorations now was meant to be a
time of Celebration Instead This is a
site of Destruction and death as the
authorities investigate the cause of the
fire it is already clear that the scale
of the damage and the loss of life is
devastating Becky Cottrell Sky News